good morning
it being 10 o'clock I'll call the fiscal
committee to order for February 17th
meeting
and entertain a motion to accept the
minutes
you have a motion a second
motion by representative Edwards second
by Senator gray to adopt the minutes
better remember to
spell that out
all in favor say aye aye opposed motion
is adopted
we have no old business
and from Tab 3 all the way through Tab
we have
all of that is on a consent calendar
because it's all fairly routine things
with the following exceptions
under Tab 8
representative Edwards has removed
FIS 23058
is also removed under tab nine FIS 23044
Senator gray has removed FIS
I would also note that item FIS
23053 has been withdrawn
and
those are the items that I withdrawn
from the entire consent calendar tabs
three through nine
Senator dalessandro thank you I would if
I could have FAS
23064 removed on uh under tab nine five
type five tab five yes
23064 is removed by Senator D'Alessandro
anything else there are many members
okay I'll entertain a motion to adopt
the rest of the consent calendar Senator
gray moves
second by
Senator Bradley
further discussion seeing none all in
favor of adopting the consent calendar
with the aforementioned items removed
I'll say I I any opposed say no
okay the rest of the consent calendar is
adopted
and we'll move to the reason we will now
move to the removed items
first item I guess being under tab eight
chap uh wait a minute tab five the one
we just removed two three zero six four
which will involve Department of
Transportation if there's anybody here
we'll have a question
thank you and will you please identify
yourselves
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm Andre Brier Deputy
Commissioner at hdot
good morning I'm Mike servertis I'm the
director of operations at hdot
thank you for coming representative
dallasandro's recognize for questions
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
coming I just wondered uh why why wasn't
any beats just a project uh considered
with this 10 meeting
why why they were not yes why why
there's nothing for Manchester in this
in this document
right okay yes sir
um
the this Consolidated list was vetted
through uh the various Congressional
offices with direct input from the
communities I know Manchester uh also uh
had a raise Grant you know kind of
simultaneously they were working I would
have to get with the city itself to uh
to understand exactly the logic of of
what was submitted and what wasn't sir
okay we can get back to you on that if
you would you yes okay thank you thank
you Mr chairman
any further questions from the committee
members on the item the Lebanon
Mechanic Street sideway sideway project
is it a sidewalk
or a sideway and what is a sideway
yeah that's that's an excellent question
sir that would be my assumption but
again I I'd have to go and look at that
okay but it's
I've never heard of a sideways I haven't
either okay sir likely a sidewalk all
right
uh shall we adopt the item committee
members
all right Senator Senator gray moves
approval Senator Rosenwald seconds are
there any further discussions on the
item seeing Nani ready for the vote all
in favor say aye aye opposed no
it is adopted thank you sir
would be under tab eight
and his item it is item
23043 Department of Health and Human
Services
and please introduce yourselves and
welcome to the fiscal committee
good morning members of the committee
wait a minute what what are you lacking
tap nine
it was there was a tab i-23058
Health and Human Services
two three zero you got it okay all right
welcome please introduce yourselves
thank you Mr chair good morning members
of the committee my name is Nathan white
Chief Financial Officer of the
Department of Health and Human Services
good morning committee my name is
Melissa Hardy I am the division director
for long-term supports and services
representative Edwards is recognized for
a question uh thank you Mr chair I I
I've got a couple questions with your
permission I'll come back to you as I go
uh overall
um my my general interest in this topic
is
um given that providing support to the
infra infant toddler part C program and
the reports that are required is
important uh I I'm generally in favor of
getting those reports done on time but
I I'm I I want to understand
how it is that we can pull money away
from providers to pay for administrative
overhead and and that question gets to
be a little sharper I think when if I
read the history here correctly this
program had the Manpower had three
people one of the people retired or went
away that job got reclassified moved to
a different department in BDS leaving
a gap there and and then this attempts
to re-establish that position that got
taken to the BDS so so how is it that
it's good for us to take money from
providers to build more administrative
overhead
or thank you for the question
representative Edwards um so I think
it's important to
um just kind of back up a little bit I'm
going to answer your question in a
slightly circulatory way so we work with
our with our federal providers to have
federally approved budgets and our
department went through the process of
developing that budget and when they did
that they determined that a portion of
the funds that we have that we have
allocated here were not allowable so
what we're actually doing and you can't
see this in the item and and I'll I'll
take fault for this is we actually have
another accounting unit 5191 where there
is a roughly there's a general Federal
match and we're going to be the the
difference that you see here will
actually be paid out of that account so
here it does appear like there's a net
reduction in payments to Providers but
what's actually happening is in the
Federal grant budget that we're working
on with the feds we're actually making
up that difference so I think I I think
you bring up a very astute point that it
does appear to be that but because of
some of the other work that we're doing
outside of here which is not part of the
technical transfer request item you're
not seeing that here and I'll take fall
for that
so so I think the summary is we're
probably aligned that we don't want to
take money from providers to pay for
administrative overhead and that and
that you've just informed me that this
this document is incomplete maybe
so would a tabling motion give you time
to fix this document
well the the the technical request is is
accurate it's it's sort of what it so so
whenever we have a contract for example
we may be paying a contract out of this
accounting unit or another accounting
unit or a series of accounting units and
and typically that would go before the
governor and executive Council and so
they would see you know they'll see
those three accounts funding that
particular effort whereas here sometimes
it can be difficult because this
requested action here is only showing
that one component
okay so Mr chair you know based on what
I have in front of me to to vote on I I
can't vote in good conscience to take
money from providers I I I would move to
itl this
okay uh motion to disapprove the item is
there a second
I'll second it for discussion okay
motion by representative Edwards
seconded by represent leishman to
disapprove the item further discussion
hi
Senator dalessandro thank you thank you
Mr uh I think that the
um
Health and Human Services has given an
explanation as to why
the document is as it is and it's
clearly stated that we're not taking any
money
and as a result of of the federal
situation you had to do it you had to do
it this way and you will produce
documentation for for the question for
for the representative that clearly
indicates that no money is being taken
away I I can't see why we should we
should not pass this issue and and get
things moving we have a very clear and
succinct explanation as to the problem
that that was brought forward and I
thought the explanation was complete and
accurate so
so why and why in essence should we
should we delay uh this this situation
we're not taking any money away which it
which I think is the key issue if you're
not taking any money away you have an
explanation and as to what's going on
and you'll have further documentation
given I I think we should proceed
forward thank you Mr stupid
representative Edwards so Mr chair
um I would like to withdraw my motion to
itl if uh if representative alishman
will support that and instead move to
table
I'll certainly support that but I do
have a question which I guess we can't
ask if the item is tabled
you may ask your question no thank you
Mr chairman I'm just curious what the
infant toddler part C program is
sure so I thank you for the question so
um it is under our family centered and
early Support Services
which is an Early Intervention Program
for children up to the age of three who
have a developmental delay and it helps
parents being the first teachers of
their children
to be able to support them in their
homes with modalities with their
developmental or perceived developmental
delay
thank you thank you Mr chairman
further discussion
so if I may then so representative
Edwards thank you Mr chair so so I think
tabling may be an order because of
public transparency this document stands
on its own and as it stands and reads
we're taking money from providers to to
build additional administrative overstay
overhead uh and that that overhead
transfer became uh necessary only
because uh Workforce was pulled from
this very Division and taken into a
different part of the department in BDS
and I as this document stands I I don't
think this is acceptable as a public
record of what we're trying to do and
what our priorities are I I recommend
tabling it so that they can fix this
document
motion to table is there a second
I see no second move to proof
Senator gray moves to prove Senator
Rosenwald seconds
any further discussion
seeing Nani ready for the question you
want to do it by hands or you want to do
it by voice
all right let's do a show of hands to
accept the item
two three four five six seven
the motion is adopted
and you are recorded as a gnome
moving on to the next item removed we'll
move to tab nine
and it is item number two three zero
four four
removed by representative Edwards again
health and human services division of
finance
welcome Mr Lipman thank you good morning
for the record Henry Lipman Medicaid
director pleased to be here this morning
representative Edwards is recognized for
a question uh thank you Mr chair uh
thank you Mr lippman I this looks like a
great opportunity we've got 51.5 million
apparently of additional fmap Monies to
to allocate uh so so and in general this
is this is a great opportunity I I just
want to understand some mechanics a
little bit better uh Givens we're so
late in the fiscal year and that this is
currently I understand I understand this
program right now to be lapsing
um I'm curious if we already have the
billing backlog to spend all this money
or or or or are there new rates that are
going to go into effect and and I and
very technically if we get a bill
in late June that we aren't able to pay
until the next fiscal year does it go
against this money or next year's money
all great questions uh representative
um so in order to make a claim you have
to incur an expense and that's when we
can make the claim so
um the way that the claiming works is
sort of on a cash basis is when we
submit
um for paid expenses on the part of the
state
um what is important that's going on now
which I think you're kind of your
question touches upon is that the
federal matching percentage after March
31st drops to five percent
um through June then it drops July 1st
to two and a half percent and after
um
after July for excuse me after from
October 1 to the end of the year it's
one and a half percent and so
um getting this item through will
maximize what is available to be claimed
on on what uh claims have been processed
by the state
so could you hit on the lapsing issue
and and when a bill becomes obligated
so it it's on a think about it on a cash
basis it's when when we the state
um either pay a capitation payment
through the mcos or
um when we pay a FIFA service claim
um it's the actual we have to actually
make the payment to the provider or in
the case of the insurer to the insurer
before we can actually make the claim
and then we have payment terms and we we
don't pay claims to I mean our our mcos
in advance so there is a by necessity a
little bit of lag to making these claims
Paula I I think I just have to uh the
okay so maybe this is a Mr White
question it I understand this money is
currently set up to lapse uh if if it's
not spent Am I Wrong is it or is this
something we're going to carry in hp2
address that one first what what is part
of this whole equation as that because
of the continuous enrollment related to
um the
um originally the ffrca and now the
Consolidated appropriation act we've had
to carry about 102 000 people that
otherwise would have been
um not on the program under normal
circumstances so what this fmap Edition
is allowing us to do is to to cover the
cost of those individuals extra if you
will and so there if there is a lapse it
would be I think a very small lapse
because we New Hampshire and I if you're
interested I can share a study on it
there's a study done by all states in
terms of what the expected fmap extra
that 6.2 percent would be against what
the expected expense of a state in New
Hampshire because
um where one of the lower fmap States in
terms of the base for standard Medicaid
50 percent
um the expectation is that our extra
fmap was just about like if you would
take 100 would be exactly matching we're
about 101 percent
um is what the forecast was in terms of
the
um extra money versus the extra cost of
covering these 102 000 people
so Mr White do you want to answer the
lapse question
in the hb2 question are do are we
changing the lapsing structure of this
in hb2 so in in the current hb2
um the Medicaid was allowed that we were
allowed to carry some of the funding
forward right now we're not projecting a
significant lapse in Medicaid uh just as
Henry alluded to because of the high
numbers that we do have on the Medicaid
rolls so we're not projecting a
significant lapse in this area at this
point
all right uh oh
I'll not ask my last question thank you
Mr chair
Senator Rosenwald is recognized thank
you Mr chairman to follow up on
representative Edward's line of
questioning I believe that last fiscal
year we did lapse as a revenue lapse
some of the additional fmap am I hearing
use state is the department committing
that we will not be lapsing
this Medicaid money as a revenue lapse
at the end of June but we'll be spending
it on the Medicaid Program
I could maybe take it and then I'll let
um so I think when we were last year we
thought that I think we all thought the
pandemic from a federal response was
going to end at various times I think
when the budget was produced we thought
it was going to end last October so I
think part of the carrying the extra
money forward really which we were
allowed under hp2 is what puts us in a
position to have enough money to cover
through the end of The Continuous
enrollment which is March 31st of this
year
pull up so it said yes
I I
based on current projections we're we're
not we're not projecting a significant
lapse I think I think the challenge and
and Henry has spoken to this a number of
times is right now you know we're moving
we're moving into a phase where
disenrollment is about to begin and we
are expecting to just enroll tens of
thousands of people in the first month
and then in the subsequent months as
well we still don't know necessarily how
many of those individuals are going to
appeal and if and if many of them appeal
they then continue to stay on Medicaid
and that's kind of a that's a big
unknown
um right now and Henry can certainly
speak more too just give you another
example that our projections
um and November are different than they
were in December because the new federal
poverty limits came out and our estimate
of how many people would uh lose
coverage was affected by 1700 people and
so I mean it's just it's that kind of
dynamic that is we no one's had
experience doing unwinding you know the
percentage of population that we're
having so I think to to if it went
perfectly with no right no um unexpected
things then then maybe we'll have a
lapse if it goes with some little
bumpiness we're going to need that money
to cover the people
but that's something we would be able to
address in-house Bill too
right if we decided we didn't want to
lapse
this money we would be able to
deal with it in tune yes we could
certainly include an hb2 provision to
allow those funds to be carried forward
further discussion on the item Mr chair
I move uh zero five zero
[Music]
motion for fis23044
all right representative Edwards moves
it second by
was it represent senator dalessandro
further discussion seeing Nani ready for
the question all in favor say aye aye
opposed no
the motion is to adopt 23. thank you
moving on to item 23050
administrative Services
excuse me
good morning please identify yourselves
good morning oops good morning this is
Sherry Rockburn I'm the assistant
commissioner for the Department of
administrative Services good morning um
I'm Dennis Goulet the commissioner of
the Department of Information Technology
Senator gray is recognized for a
question uh thank you the item talks
about State's Financial payroll system
and sustainability talks about the
existing system being 14 years old and
goes on to talk about
procure services and a variety of
functions and Technical experts to
ensure and
don't have any problem with accepting
the money I just want to make sure that
companies out there get a fair shot if
we are going to expend 15 million
dollars and would encourage you to
comment
um so a few things that I wanted to to
talk about in terms of our system so as
the item states that the our current
accounting system which includes
accounting payroll budgeting Etc
um has been in place for a little over
14 years and I think as Dennis will talk
about that's pretty ancient when it
comes to software back when we did that
we did a full RFP to procure a new Erp
system enterprise resource system and
that took quite a while to implement and
that's the system we've been working
with
um what we are realizing is that our
current vendor will no longer support
our version that we're on after April of
2026 so we'll be in a situation where
we'll have no support to maintain our
system with a vendor after that period
so we've been looking into what are our
three options in order to keep the
state's books rolling and payroll and
budgeting Etc one option would be to do
nothing and you know have in-house try
to manage that system without any vendor
support not highly recommended but
obviously an option that would be
minimal to no cost but not a great
product at the end on the Other Extreme
we could do a completely new RFP and try
to re-procure an entire new system and
the third option being we can upgrade
our current vendor to the next version
and that's what this proposal is
recommending is to upgrade the version
to the latest version with our current
vendor it's a look as it looks a
substantial amount of money to do the
upgrade but a brand new procurement is
going to cost in tune of greater than
100 million Idaho just did it they're in
the process of going live in the next
year and Idaho right now is at 102.4
million was our estimate for a brand new
our RFP system sorry a new RFP to incur
to procure a new system so that's where
this 15 while it's a lot of money our
recommendation is not to re-procure an
entire new system but to do an upgrade
the Consultants that we use with the
project we can you know RFP and look for
Consultants to help us implement but as
of now we weren't looking to procure a
brand new system so I'll pause on that
for a minute
so so a little a little further on that
topic um the the
um we we did look at at a number of
different
um
numbers that related to a full
reprocurement of Erp system it's it's
its orders of magnitude more expensive
than this path to
um you know to have essentially what we
already have today so
um we thought the best path was to to
move forward with the incumbent in four
although this this isn't a contract to
do that this that would be our plan for
that part of it
thank you
Senator D'Alessandro was recognized for
a question thank you Mr achievement and
first of all thanks Sherry thank you for
that explanation and uh great great to
see both of you if if we do purchase the
new rev how many revs are in place
as we as we go forward now you know
they're constantly revving this stuff up
when does that end because as as you
said uh they're not going to support it
so what revs on the street as we as we
speak do we do we purchase that rev and
who supports that rev going forward well
um it's a good question and and I I'm
glad you asked it because one of the
changes that we're making as part of
this is we're we're adopting
um a their what they call their Cloud
Suite package and what that does is it
it shifts the burden of upgrading from
us to them over time so essentially it's
something we wouldn't be worried about
doing anymore ourselves and which is
great because when we have to upgrade
it's very it's a ton of work and it's
very disruptive to both administrative
services in my department and
potentially the the rest of the state if
anything goes wrong which you know
sometimes does so this this takes that
off the table completely
so by making this move and this
procuring this particular situation
we're going to be okay
yes I think we'll be better off than we
are
um from a stability and a supportability
perspective okay thank you thank you Mr
further discussion on the item
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair so
RIT installed base is enormous and we're
seeing this one instance of a an I.T
system that needs to be upgraded
um I I would think that we generally
would have update and upgrade contracts
in place for all the key components of
our infrastructure I'm assuming this is
really just about making sure it's
funded it it leaves me to to worry
though about our entire installed base
you know is there is there
um an undiscussed Bill outstanding of
what it's going to cost us to upgrade
everything over the next four or five
years is that part of a part of your I.T
strategic plan where you can show people
exactly where this system sits in your
constellation what its upgrade plan is
what its ultimate replacement plan is
and all of the siblings around it
there's there's two parts to the answer
to that so I'll hit on both of them one
is that you know all of the systems have
you know we call an application life
cycle and and so that you have to look
at every application and and we have
over 600 large applications in the
executive branch of government right now
and
um some extra large applications which I
call this our Erp falls into that extra
large category the other two extra
larges are in in health and human
services and I think you're pretty
familiar with the life cycle work we're
doing there on eligibility and and
Medicaid systems so we do look at that
for every system we don't always have
the money to do the right thing but in
the case that we do and particularly if
it gets critical we looked we look to do
that so so that is a regular thing we do
we look at the life cycle we recommend
moving to um you know and sometimes
we're forced to do it right if it's
running on a say an infrastructure
that's going to be no longer supported
or something like that that's one factor
life cycle the other factor is many
software vendors are going away from
their traditional way of selling and
Licensing software and in and this is an
example of that so rather than having
these big license deals every once in a
while while and then getting 15 or 22
percent or Seventeen percent maintenance
over time what they're doing is they're
shifting away from that and going to
subscription based and they're often
doing that in the cloud which is again
the case here so that this Erp app once
we complete this transition would be
sitting in in the cloud rather than in
my data center at 27 Hazen and that's
why that's how they're able to maintain
and manage the life cycle of that app on
our behalf going forward
so what I probably a poorly worded
question I'm I'm concerned about the it
portfolio and how many more of these
kind of upgrade bills are outstanding
that we don't have visibility as a
legislature on uh oh well say let's say
we have if we have 600 over 600 apps
then there are 600 apps that at some
point will have to be updated
and then we look at that all the time we
see contracts going you know we're we're
re-procuring um so so each time we have
a a cusp this is I would call this a
cusp for the Erp system we have to look
at it and say all right what's the right
thing to do here I'll just give an
example of of uh you know uh
where we look at the app itself and we
say what's the best thing to do here we
can again do nothing and keep running it
or try to support it in-house which
generally a bad idea re-procure and in
in some cases that may be the right
thing because the app itself or the
vendor itself doesn't have a go forward
and and then the the third option would
be to continue with that vendor but use
their new product and then typically to
to determine that we we would often do
an RFI so we have some recent examples
where we did an RFI discovered that you
know staying with the incumbent was much
less expensive than than re fully
reprocuring and so we did that so in in
a sense it was somewhat competitive but
not as competitive as a full
re-procurement RFP would be
so we we're always constantly doing that
and yes we will be seeing bills to you
know we will see costs continuously as
long as we're running I.T systems for uh
to address life cycle issues in the
executive branch
okay
further discussion on the item vote for
proof Senator gray moves to approve item
23050 second by Senator Alessandro
any further discussion
seeing Nani ready for the question all
in favor say aye aye opposed no the item
is adopted
moving on to the regular calendar
after tab 11.
the first item we see is 23061
Department of Safety
is there a question or a motion
move the item
representative lesion leishman moves to
adopt item 23061 Senator Birdsall in
seconds
further discussion
seeing none are you ready for the
question all in favor say aye aye
opposed no
that item is adopted
next item on the regular calendar under
tab 12.
foreign
23065 Department of Transportation
I think there were going to be some
questions on this one
Senator representative leishman
thank you Mr chairman
welcome please identify yourself morning
Mr chairman for the record uh Andre
briart Deputy Commissioner at hdot
and good morning Mr chairman
um Mike servertis I'm the director of
operations at DOD
Senator leishman's recognized for a
question
again you know I guess I better run next
time but
uh thank you Mr chairman
so uh on page two it mentions the
expenditure for salt also reflects an
increase in material cost since the
current budget was developed two years
ago do you get a bid for your salt like
are you able to bid more than a year out
or how does that work
um it's pretty much bid annually through
purchasing property
so follow-up question I could Mr
chairman follow up
so your request is really only for 2023
the budget year it's not for 2022 in
other words
you
if I could explain it further according
to your chart you show that the increase
in 2022 was 27.5 and then
20 in 23. so I'm assuming the request is
just for this year not yeah it's for
additional materials to take us through
this year if you can't bid in advance
for right what we we do try to uh we we
have various mechanisms and strategies
to try to procure the cheapest salt that
we can we do that uh at various times of
the year uh and look for that with those
windows of opportunity to fill our sheds
in this case the price of salt like so
many other materials increase
significantly uh over over this past
year okay thanks thank you Mr chairman
Senator gray is recognized for question
when I got this item I went directly to
the LBA and I said why have I got 825
000 in benefits and when I look at the
top of the item I don't see any salaries
I don't see I see current expenses which
is the salt and then I see leases and
rents so apparently your books got out
of whack at some point and you've now
realized that you're going to shorten
our employees almost a million dollars
in benefits yes sir thank you for the
question what this is and this is
actually
um a
it's not an optimal process but this is
very normal for us to come at this point
of the season and make these types of
requests the things that are going on
just big picture
with regard to Winter maintenance our uh
the increased price of salt in our high
vacancy rate those are the two primary
things that are going on these transfers
you see represent uh
increase contract rates for Contract
Health because we do have a high vacancy
rate we have to rely more heavily on our
uh on our rental rented vehicles and our
rented drivers that that are produced by
that are provided to us by contractors
so that the changes in the budget lines
you see cover those expenses for looking
forward for the rest of this season
what you've told me thank you what
you've told me is that if I'm going to
do more Contracting out
then this benefits line should be going
down not going up because I pay the
contract price which includes the
benefits for their employees and if I'm
substituting my employees what I expect
to see when I've got an increase in
benefits is an increase in Personnel
costs more personality it's over time
it's overtime sir is what that is so so
there's a there's a couple strategies we
use this year because of our vacancy
rate one is volunteers from within the
department and we got authority to do
that also externally to to dot we have a
few people that are voluntary who have
CDL licenses
because everybody's pedaling harder
because everybody's working more to
cover those vacancies these are the
benefits line you see is largely over
time
to because we have large storms we don't
have shifts you know these people when
they start plowing they keep plowing
until a storm event is concluded
for me I will have a further
ba on this item because
um
you know where I come from uh benefits
for overtime are severely reduced from
the benefits for a full-time employee
because you don't incur all this these
are full-time employees sir and so well
whatever whatever you know the full-time
rate because if I budgeted full-time
rate I should have also budgeted the
benefits at that and again I I when I
get these I do try to understand them so
I can answer maybe uh something that
that may address your question and that
is when we calculate these numbers we
base it on three-year averages
so if you can incorporate the last three
years into this budget forecast that we
use to come up with our original numbers
projecting forward for this winter
season
inflationary effects are much greater
than in the earlier part of that
three-year window
so that's that is how we budget and that
has been traditionally successful you
know in a normal three-year window
because uh you know you don't get these
huge spikes in inflation in this case we
we do
and we also have huge spikes and vacancy
rates so that's that's an aberration in
this three-year window and that is why
you see the amounts that you see that
we're requesting to move
I'll continue this with Mike after the
meeting and we'll go from there I'll
move the item thank you sir
Senator gray moves the item senator
we'll come back to that Senator bird
cell seconds the item
um
further discussion representative
policeman
thank you Mr chairman and I guess I'm
also a little confused or concerned is
Senator gray is on this matter
hmm
what are your what do you set aside for
a percentage for benefits because if I
look at what your
putting down for a benefits it doesn't
really correlate with an increase in
your payroll line because that should be
going up
for the overtime but you're showing a
benefit line of an increase of 825 000
which seems excessive based on what
you're asking for increased per pay or
as you try as you explained
um
if you look at on page two winter
maintenance it says increased expense is
a million dollars so I assume maybe
that's your payroll
but a corresponding benefit of 825 it
just doesn't line up for me
yes sir again the best way I could
explain this is that our volunteers so
the volunteer employees that are filling
the gap for winter maintenance are for
the most part already full-time
employees we're not adding employees to
to do that
so as a result you know we already have
them on our payroll what you're seeing
is they're working more hours
which normally would be reflected in the
overtime line
but the overtime line doesn't move up
yeah I can what we can do is go back and
get you a more detailed answer if you'd
like that answer sir that's that's the
uh and again this is prospective not
retrospective
so these uh moving these numbers gets us
through the rest of this winner
could these be bonuses to the drivers
that wouldn't go into overtime or salary
would have to go into benefit or
something the well it does in part
reflect the enhancement that the uh the
winner folks are receiving in the
benefits applied to that but I I'm not
they don't really get bonuses you know
that those are kind of already
calculated in there the winner
maintainers get a stipend
um those are the ones that are DOT
employees and then they have the
enhancement that got us up from about 40
volunteers up to 90 but
um well in the past in Winter
maintenance we see big increases both in
in overtime
and then pay and then then it would go
to benefits as the pay increase but this
is an unusual place to put benefits at a
big increase without increasing I do see
your questions sir and and uh
if you'd like we can I mean I can assure
you we'll get you that answer thank you
further discussion from the committee
all right we have a motion and a second
to accept the item
further discussion seeing none all in
favor say aye aye opposed no
the item is adopted we'll wait to see
further information we will follow up
sir thank you thank you
okay moving on to informational items
are there any questions from any of the
members on informational items
Senator Rosemont
um I think it's a last meeting we didn't
get to
congratulate the LBA audit okay
I will ask
Stephen Smith to come forward director
of audits
and I will ask you all to turn to item
FIS 22429
[Music]
it's it's in the information was under
tab 14.
and good morning Miss Sharon
I will note
the national legislative
National Conference of state
legislatures has recognized and
presented
to New Hampshire office of legislative
budget assistant audit division and
recognition of its support that had
significant impact on public policy the
adult parole board and the members will
now be named and recognized before us
Mr Smith
sure on the on this particular audit
vile skids was the audit manager and
assisting her were Paige Lorenz
please stand
and in the military they make you come
forward and stand at attention while
people honor you so
and then lastly Andrea Provost
was uh Jay Henry our Performance Auto
supervisor is ill so is not able to make
it today so but uh so we thank you very
much for your recognition audit division
works for this committee yes your work
is Paramount to what we do
we recognize what you do we appreciate
all the work you do I specifically read
everything you write
and so I think you're great please all
rise and give them a hand
[Applause]
thank you all for your recognition
thank you Mr Smith
and I guess the next items are yours as
well yes that was good
moving on to the audits of Fidelity
advisor plan
foreign
thank you Mr chair
um we're here to present the college
savings plans and as you may know our
office retains PWC
accounting firm to perform these audits
um
and with us is Declan Barn
he's the partner for PWC and also Monica
mitsapelli from our state treasurer to
respond to any questions or anything she
might want to add to to the audit so
with that I'll turn it over to Declan
thank you very much
um it's my pleasure to be here again
um uh usually one of the highlights of
my year to come to present to the
college saving plan which again I come
bearing good news
um so I do we did provide a handout in
advance I won't do Page by Page
um but we will
um I promise
um but we will do a quick overview of
the results of the audit
um and Alice even said by way of
introduction Declan burn partner in
Boston
um so so our materials I would say are
pretty standard compared to Prior year
and the audits were pretty efficient I
think we we got lucky with no big
changes in Accounting Standards this
year or financial reporting so we're
able to get through the order as
efficiently as always with the help of
our friends at Fidelity who who do the
books and Records so I'll just highlight
on page six actually that's really the
executive summary or so sorry page five
that's really the executive summary of
the audit which really captures captures
everything we can talk today so in terms
of significant changes to the order plan
we we start this audit back in back
September so we we speak with Monica we
work with Fidelity and thankfully no
major changes in the execution of the
ordered as we went through and they did
this fall and I'm getting the audit
signed off and from a a report was
unqualified so as you I did want and
expect
um from a reportable item standpoint we
have nothing significant to note no
material weaknesses no fraud no
non-compliance
no uncorrect misstatements or or even
errors we found in financial statements
that were subsequently corrected by
management we do rely significantly on
Fidelity as the server provider they
have um a good books and Records a
system of control which is governed by
uh sock ones and and we we spend a lot
of time with them making sure they're
accounting further transactions the
participants balances timely accurately
and appropriately valued and that really
covers the substance of our other work
that we we perform and we do have we did
have some new portfolios this year which
we we delved into uh the stable value
portfolios in the the sustainability
portfolios we made sure and that the the
books and records and the operational
processing of of those types of products
were were in line with our expectations
and as designed and and no issues noted
there so again for that we were
comfortable with the system of control
around that
and then I'll just turn briefly to to
page seven as we look at these other
standard uh required Communications
under Professional Standards and again
just these are pretty standard areas
around fraud and non-compliance again
nothing was noted I'd highlight the
quality of plans financial statements as
one area and we continue to work with
Fidelity on the on the the disclosures
and presentation and quality of the work
they do as they design and implement the
financial statements allowing
Professional Standards and and all of
those we do highlight some of the newer
disclosures uh as node into portfolios
but again everything in line was in our
expectations and fed into our own
unqualified opinion
and then or maybe turning to page nine I
think that's just reaffirms no matters
to know from a difficulty in terms of
the execution of the audish and no
contentious matters uh dialogue was good
open uh fruitful about Monica team and
as well as Fidelity so overall
um we're pretty pleased with these
results we're doing the appendix that do
provide you know the PWC quality report
just an overview of PWC as a firm as as
we we take um inequality and our
responsibility to the capital markets
and indeed you
um as it relates to the quality in our
audits as well as the standard reports
and their Auto report our management
representation letter and legal letter
all of which I would say are pretty
standard and of course nothing came back
in our legal letter to say there wasn't
do we need to delve into any legal
matters because there are no legal
matters at standing in the plan so so
overall
um you know good results
um you know again we thank Monica team
and and indeed also thanks Steven as I
learned he's retiring today and for his
work and um it was great to be here
again but uh maybe I'll pause if any
questions
Senator Dallas thank you very much thank
you Mr Achievement First of all uh
there's there's nothing more melodious
than the tone of your voice
it's wonderful and I I anticipate this
yearly conversation
it's very meaningful and and I certainly
appreciate it appreciate the work that
that you do uh this this program
has been extremely beneficial to New
Hampshire I don't think there's any
question about that and and the fact
that it's still an ongoing situation
that and that Fidelity has made the
kinds of changes that we've suggested at
a series of our meetings to enhance the
program I think a a well recognize but
as I say uh it's the audit presentation
that makes it all worthwhile
thank you so thank you so much I I truly
appreciate it thank you Mr Champion the
highlight of my year
representative Edwards
uh thank you very much Mr chairman I I
just want to understand a little bit
about
um with the reference on page 12
there's a reference that on your audit
quality you look into ESG reporting and
then as I look at the report itself I'm
not seeing actually any section of your
audit that dealt with ESG
and so so is there an incongruence issue
here that I need to understand no no I I
our focus on quality is a firm based and
as we focus on providing Assurance to
ESG into right areas does knock um and
so this is a firm level on these audits
in particular there's there's no ESG
component is purely on the financial
statements that we provide an audit
opinion and so that there's really no
connection between our firm level
um and other engagements we might do
reports on ESG but not in this instance
follow-up
um is there anything in New Hampshire's
guidance or laws uh or at the federal
level that is pushing you or compelling
you to include ESG auditing and in your
reports no no not this point in time and
there's there's certainly things that
the SEC for public companies around
certain disclosures that uh registrants
are required but in this instance under
the framework of the fosby and aicpa
which we report on there is nothing
pushing us to report anything on ESG and
then one last follow-up
is is I I the little bit of reading I've
done on this may be totally biased so
I'm asking you your opinion as an
auditor
the reporting I've seen indicates that
the companies that comply closest with
ESG standards or guidelines or
principles I guess they're really
principles
that their rate of return on their
Investments tend to actually be lower
than the corporations and Investments
that do not issue the ESG principles is
is that what can you say anything about
in general uh the relationship between
ESG compliance and race relative rates
of return yeah it's probably not my area
honestly of expertise so I probably
can't comment I'm aware of all the the
commentary in the in the open in the
markets but from from our vantage point
is what we what's in front of us and do
the audits we don't get involved in in
those types of um
uh you know areas so I can't really
speak with authority on that topic if I
be be honest
and I'll just agree I love your voice
but
further from the members
like to recognize uh Madam Treasurer any
comments
it's a terror members of the committee
for the record State treasure Monica
mazzapelli uh and again this is also a
time when I get to just share the good
news uh with with all of you and want to
thank Mr Smith and Mr Baron for for
their work
um certainly
um this there's a lot of work involved
to audit all these funds and this
portfolios uh but you know we've had PWC
for for a few years so they know
um and they've always done a very
efficient and good quality work so we're
very thankful for that and the same for
our program manager Fidelity Investments
obviously they're the ones that put the
financial statements together and they
maintain the controls in order to have a
clean opinion so we're grateful for that
um so it's all good news a clean opinion
and I'm always happy to be here to share
that so um and just to add to to the
good news um you know again this
continues to be a very successful
program
um in the country is still the large the
fourth largest plan in the country with
about 21 billion dollars under ass and
under assets under management
um so this year the the plan had a
little bit of rough year just like
everyone else but in US is on its way uh
to full recovery so again all good news
we have about 800 000 participant
accounts
um and again our goal is to continue
growing this plan to to benefit New
Hampshire families and families around
the country that want to participate in
this plan and as you all know we we
benefit from a revenue share that we
obtain from from this plan and
um in fiscal year 22 we received about
19 million dollars and we were able to
distribute those funds and scholarships
so
um do we help New Hampshire families and
New Hampshire students we provided about
7 200
scholarships that range from one
thousand to uh 10 000. so again all good
news and I know the commission members
of the commission are part of this this
committee and it's all
um thanks to the commission members that
also in first grade 23 there are plans
to expand the eligibility to provide
more scholarships to New Hampshire
students and to provide them a larger
award amount so again all good news and
I want to thank you all of you for
um for your attention and um I'll be
happy to answer any questions
thank you madam Treasurer
um I think that's worthy of publicity
that 19 million dollars I was looking
through the unique plan hoping to find
it highlighted but I couldn't find it
in in what paid you to be highlighted on
this that that report is with uh
Fidelity puts together as really mainly
the financial statements
um for each of the portfolios so that's
that's what that represents so it's all
separated except it's separate yes okay
that's why I didn't I was looking for a
figure like that and didn't see it
anywhere we probably have to uh prepare
a different publication to highlight you
know the the in addition to the annual
report or the treasury but for all the
additional publication to Highlights
those benefits that we have as a result
of this successful plan
thank you representative Edwards for a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you madam Treasurer I um I'll ask you
the question maybe it would have been
more appropriate to you anyways are you
aware of anything in New Hampshire law
or rules uh that either
requires our our investments that you
manage to adhere or comply with ESG
principles or alternatively to avoid the
ESG
principles to highlight instead the
fiduciary responsibility to the investor
thank you for the question Mr
representative Edwards I um I believe
there are nothing really that binds us
or or the regulation or law that
um provides that guidance
um in terms of the 529 plan
um there is a
um as Mr burn mentioned there's there is
a portfolio with an ESG component fidela
introduced that portfolio and and the
reason for that is it was more to
provide an option to participants it's a
standalone portfolio
um
that has that sustainability component
and it doesn't it is not well what I
understand the the other portfolios that
the hbase portfolios or the other
Standalone portfolios don't have an EST
component this is the only portfolio
that provides that option to those
investors who are interested in
essentially putting their money in in
that type of investment so it's more to
provide the option in the variety in
order to
and again this is to
um
and listening to participants or
investors out there in order to grow the
plan and be more comprehensive this new
portfolio was was was added in terms of
the composition of that portfolio I
believe I have to get back to you but if
I recall correctly because I don't have
that detail here but I believe it's a
it's a mix of us about 70 percent equity
and 30 percent
um Bond a more conservative Investments
so the participants should know when
they are investing in this type of fund
the type of um
the type of portfolio or the type of
strategy that they're choosing uh to
invest their funds so I think it's all
this close it's all disclosed and the
proper documents
um
but there's no particular regulation
especially in New Hampshire that that
um
that will provide that guidance or
specific protection if you want to call
it it's more
um I believe as Mr Burr mentioned that
the SEC is trying to issue guidance but
there's really nothing right now that
exists that I'm aware of
any further discussion from the
committee members
seeing none
thank you all for your work and this we
have already had a motion to adopt and
place on file in the usual manner so we
don't need that again
good to see you all thank you all very
much for your fine work
thank you
next on our agenda would be to pick next
month's meeting
I think uh Mr Kane and I talked about
maybe moving to the fourth Friday
because of some of the deadlines that
we're working in in the house if that
doesn't interfere with the schedule for
the Senate that would be the 24th for
the fourth Friday
other than the Third
it could take a minute to see what
what's on your schedule
Senator Rosenwald thank you I know that
Health and Human Services oversight is
scheduled for the morning and the 24th
that involves three of you well
yeah a bunch of us all right three
senators and at least one Houseman all
right so that's that's going to keep you
busy
um how about so if we go back to the
17th
or we could move to the afternoon some
people don't like the afternoon
is that a problem if we go to the you'd
probably be done with your committee by
noon
yes
we can do the 31st too which is the last
five weeks in March
that's right we do have a
another Friday
is the 31st preferable
I can do either the afternoon on the
24th or the 31st
same here since I'm going to be here
anyway on the 24th true of like one
o'clock on the 24th would work very well
for me well the uh agenda we've had
today hasn't been too lengthy we could
Gamble and hope it would happen again
we've only been about an hour so
you
let's do the 24th at 1 pm
if that works and uh does it work for
the LBA
okay
all right our next meeting will be
um
March 24th at 1 o'clock at 1 pm in the
afternoon
um do we anticipate
much do we know anything I should have
asked Mr Smith if he had it he was going
to dump three uh
audits on us or something we can control
it I'll talk to the chair we can hold
whatever you need especially since
you're meeting later we might have some
management letters but we can hold those
until April if we need to but I'll I'll
monitor the agenda to see the size and
then I'll notify you all in your good
hands okay
if there's nothing further to come
before us I appreciate the alternates
from this the house side always showing
up and staying in touch with all the
agenda thank you very much
that's not hasn't been customary in the
past for uh for alternates but I
appreciate it
thank you all the motion to adjourn is
in order
motion by Senator D'Alessandro second by
Senator gray that we adjourn at this
time all in favor say aye
the post no motion is adopted thank you
all for coming thank you for the fine
work of the LBA and and as Mr Smith I
was going to ask him if we go to the
afternoon of the 24th
uh would we expect multiple
um audits that we'd be reviewing on that
day or likely no
just letters yeah okay
thank you very much and appreciate you
bringing your folks out here today
I wanted to give him some recognition
I want them to make sure they know we
appreciate their work
oh
my God